Five years ago,
we had five unicorns based out of India.
Now, we have about 24,
and we expect
there'll be another 50 unicorns
in the next five years.
Saket Agarwal,
thank you so much for joining me.
How are you?
I'm awesome.
Fantastic.
Are you calling from India right now?
Yes, yes.
I'm based out of Mumbai.
So, you're based out of Mumbai,
yet your hashtag
is "Your Israel tech guy" right?
Yes, yes. Your Israel guy.
I'm in Israel.
So, this is going to be a lot of fun
because I'm going to be learning
so much from this call.
Besides for the fact
that you're an accountant
and you're the co ambassador
of the Singularity University chapter
of Mumbai,
you are extremely passionate
about the intersection
of Israel and in India tech ecosystems.
So, this is a world
where I know very little about,
and I know very little about
the India tech ecosystem.
And that's why I'm so excited
to hear your insights
and what's happening today.
But before we get into all that,
who are you
and what is your journey
into this tech world?
Yeah, thanks, thanks
for having me on the show.
I'm really excited.
So, I started on aviation
about five years ago.
I'm an accountant by qualification.
And the thesis is that
every time I went to the US,
I would eat at Chipotle
or I would sit on a Tesla,
and then I would wonder
why aren't these companies
coming to India.
And the natural realization was
they would ideally go to the US first
because US is the media market to crack.
And one fine day I went to Israel
and I saw that
so many disruptive technologies
also going to the US,
not looking in India.
But Israelis loved Indians
because you guys come to India.
After the army.
So I thought,
why not explore this corridor
where I identify the most disruptive
Israeli SaaS companies,
identify their market for India,
hire a team,
and run their entire business.
So, I went for a 17 day trip to Israel.
Literally met a hundred companies,
so many people.
And towards the end I got lucky.
I met a company called, Spot.io.
Yes.
Which was recently acquired by NetApp
for $450,000,000.
So, Spot essentially
helps you optimize your AWS costs
by 80%.
Being an accountant,
it just resonated with me.
And
I was like,
okay, why not explore this.
So, I got them to India,
hired a bunch of folks
to review a decent chunk
of the revenue for Spot.
Almost all the big e-commerce,
media and gaming companies,
everyone's a customer.
And then we realized,
since we have more hundred customers
using Spot,
how do we sell them everything else?
So, over a period of time,
we've got a portfolio
of 15 Israeli companies.
We run their India business.
We've hired
professional sales folks for them
and we're like their extended arm.
So, first of all, it's amazing.
And I think that on one hand,
you're doing a great service
to Israeli tech companies.
On the other hand,
you're doing a great service
to the companies in India
by bridging this gap.
Because obviously,
it's a huge win-win.
Let's go back to the problem.
Why do Israelis and Americans
not look at their business
to the Indian market?
We're talking about
more than a billion people.
We're talking about potentially,
and the glass ceiling is so high
you can't even see it
in terms of the potential business.
To me, it makes perfect sense
when I build a business,
I want to also go to the India market.
Why is it so hard
or people don't do it?
Yeah.
So, the natural answer is,
US is a comfort zone
for every Israeli, right?
You've been there,
you've stayed there,
you have so many family,
and you have so many friends
and family members running
big corporations in the US ecosystem.
So, it's always easier
to tap into the US
because you are aware.
India, on the other hand,
is a slightly unknown territory.
So, you need a lot of guidance
in order to find a greater market.
The second thing is,
India has a large population,
not necessarily a large market
for every product, unlike the US.
So, what do you want to bring into India
has to be very, very well thought to.
Does it for the Indian market
well or not;
will you be able to make
a big business out of it or not,
is a key question.
So,
if you are able to scale
a hundred companies in the US,
the same number would reduce to 10
if you would bring those companies
into India if you want to see scale.
Interesting.
Right?
So, that is one of the media reasons
when a company
is looking at their options,
where do they want
to expand first.
They naturally do it in the US
than in India.
So, can you give me
a little bit of background
into the Indian market.
What is the tech ecosystem like?
Who are the customers?
And then what I love to talk about is,
maybe understanding a little bit
the different cultural habits
that maybe hinder
the relationships to scale
from 10 to 100 companies.
Yeah, yeah.
So, in terms of the
Indian tech landscape,
I'll give you some context.
Five years ago we had
five unicorns based out of India.
Now, we have about 24,
and we expect there'll be another
50 unicorns in the next five years.
So, just to repeat that.
So, five years ago,
you had five unicorns.
That's about the number that Israel had,
I guess maybe
five, 10 years ago, right, as well.
And now, you have 24.
And you're expecting to double that
in the next five years.
Correct. More than double.
We expect about a hundred unicorns.
So, a couple of things,
the digital landscape
is really exploding in India right now.
So, we've seen like a 100x growth
in terms of start up
Internet penetration since 2010.
All the venture capital funds are now
prioritizing India in a big way.
To give you context,
Sequoia Capital recently raised
a big funding round
of $1.35 billion,
only and only
to invest in Indian tech startups.
Right?
So, suddenly, there's a massive push
towards digital adoption,
digital transformation.
So, the payment infrastructure
that India has
is actually the most advanced
across the world.
So, if I were to transfer you money
sitting in India,
I can do it under 30 seconds
using a unique UPI ID,
which is linked to your mobile phone.
Right.
Or if I have to access a doctor,
there are several apps that are available
that can help me do video consultation
or order online medicines right away.
We can get food delivery in 30 minutes
in such a massive country.
Like Mumbai itself is maybe 10x
the population of Israelis,
but we've been able to handle that scale
in a very digital friendly way,
very, very successfully.
I think that one of the things that
I am underestimating
and I'm guessing that a lot of people
in my community
are underestimating is that,
having 30-minute food deliveries
or a 30-second payment system
in a place like Mumbai,
which is 10x Israel,
that expansion,
it makes perfect sense
why you may take a little bit longer,
but when it gets there,
it has to be so much more robust
and foundational
to be able to handle that scale, right?
I mean, we're talking about
a massively different problem.
And I think that one of the things
that I'm understanding and I'm really,
when you're talking about this 10x growth
and the hundred unicorns
in the next few years,
I'm surprised that I'm not seeing
every headline talk about
the amazing things
that are coming out of India.
Because in my news feed
that is tailored for me,
I'm seeing the tech ecosystem in Israel,
the tech ecosystem in Palo Alto,
in Seattle, in New York.
But I'm missing out on what sounds like
the really the next huge market
that is going to be
the tech innovator of the world.
Absolutely. Absolutely.
So, one thing I want to highlight is
our strength in India has been B2C,
wherein the Israel has been very strong
on the B2B side.
I miss I think, something last IPL.
IPL is Indian Premier League.
It's one of the biggest
cricketing tournaments in India.
The final match had 25,000,000
concurrent users.
So, 25,000,000 people
were watching the finals of that match
at a single point, right,
which is a global record.
A global record.
It's more than the Oscars,
the Super Bowl,
the [--].
I think so.
So, we are seeing a lot of scale
and that's where
we're saying
will solve a problem
for every individual,
a billion and a half people in India.
Where we sort of need a lot of help
is depth on the technology front,
which is where Israel comes into play.
You have the best data scientist,
the best cybersecurity professionals
and the best marketing
ad-tech professionals.
The industry is very strong there.
These companies are scaling so fast.
To give you context,
the largest fantasy sports
platform in India
is a company called, Dream11,
which is now valued
at $2.5 billion.
The mass, the media grew this all
was in the last two years.
Now, the fact that
they're scaling so fast,
they need the best of data science,
best of security,
best of QA,
the best of cloud infrastructure
and monitoring solutions.
And that's where they look at Israel,
which is really, really strong
in these areas.
And that's where I see a big synergy
between the two countries.
So, I'm just trying to synthesize
for myself.
It sounds like
what you're saying is that
there has been a great shift
in the market in the past few years
that tech companies are emerging
to provide local solutions to
one of the biggest places in the world.
So, these are solutions
that we've seen already
in the Western world
five, 10 years ago.
They are now being brought
into the Indian culture
by Indian tech companies.
And now there is this weird limbo zone
where you still
have an opportunity
to implement the great technologies
from Israel
at the scale of India.
And there is a win-win.
And what's missing there right now
is more people like you
that are making that connection, right?
Absolutely.
What is even more interesting is
a few Israeli companies
were initially very excited
about the scale that they would get
in the US.
They are now surprised
by the scale they see in India.
You know, 25,000,000
concurrent users is Android
and which is also helping
the Israeli companies
prepare their product
for a much, much more higher scale.
All these Indian companies
become design partners
for such startups in Israel.
Right.
Now, do you have
any connection to Israel?
Why are you so excited about
making this bridge?
What got you into this?
Yeah. Look,
I just landed in Israel,
I met a few people,
and the love and warmth
I got from everyone was incredible.
And I just got started with one company
and then it just kept on building.
I had no real,
you know, I'm not even a techie
so, for me, cloud was cloud.
So, the journey has purely been
very, very random.
I picked a country I knew nothing about.
I did one thing, it became successful.
And I said, why not build up on it.
And because Israel
is such a strong brand, right?
When I say
I bring US companies into India
or European companies into India,
there are too many people doing it.
With Israel,
I was able to build a very strong niche
and now I am truly like,
one of the leading guys
in the tech ecosystem
bridging the gap.
Wow.
And so, what is your method?
How do you go about
finding the synergy?
Because it sounds like
you have to have
both feet in both places.
You have to know
what are the new emerging technologies
in Israel,
and what are the emerging markets
and who are the key players
that you can now
knock on their door and say,
hey, you now have the need
to supply something
to 20,000,000 people,
here is a technology
that might be able to assist you?
Yeah. Yeah.
That's a great question, actually.
So, first of all,
I personally visit Israel
every other month.
Wow.
Yeah.
I've built relationships with almost
all the big venture capital funds,
all the accelerators in Israel.
All of them are familiar
with our work in India.
The kind of success we've generated,
and you know how Israelis
want to generate success
for one company.
What we did with Spot, for example,
it became very, very popular.
So, the moment that a great company
that is born, they are saying,
okay, you are looking at the US market,
why don't you also look
at India as a market.
So, I can give you a data point.
There are three companies
that we represent in India today.
All of them have raised upwards
of $40,000,000 in funding each
and we do 20% of their global revenue.
Wow.
Right.
Because of this good word,
VCs started connecting us
to a company
the moment they invest in them.
The third thing that I started doing
was I personally started
investing in these companies.
So, I've invested in
two venture capital funds
as an LP in Israel.
That gives me access
to the best deal flows.
The moment the startup is born
I have access to them.
And I recently invested
in a company called Dataloop,
which was backed by a few NDB.
I know him well. Eran.
Yeah.
Yes.
It's a great company.
And what we're doing is,
we're saying,
not only will help you sell,
but since we're running sales for you,
we have so much value.
Give us some allocation
to co-invest with big VCs.
And lastly, I would say,
since we have one hundred plus customers
and all our customers are the largest
e-commerce, media and gaming companies,
unicorns,
they keep sharing with us.
You know, personalization
is a big problem,
warehouse automation is a big problem.
Customer acquisition cost
for gaming company
are a huge issue.
Are there solutions in Israel
that are solving it?
Some of them even come to Israel with us
and we make them meet
different companies.
So, that's how we get
a lot of problem statement.
And then I would go to a VC and ask them,
you know, is there someone in Israel
solving this?
And someone in Israel is always solving
some problem on the other for sure.
And I could assume very well
that if you come with an actual problem
that somebody needs a solution for,
even if there is not a solution now,
there will be somebody
who is willing to pick up the glove
and to do the right thing.
Correct. Correct.
So, I love thinking ahead
and imagining what type of world
we're going to be living in.
Obviously this past year
has been very monumental for me
and thinking about
what are the different things
that are going to change,
and how do I need to adapt
as an entrepreneur and as an engineer
to this changing world due to covid.
But I'm curious now about
the Indian tech ecosystem
and Israelis tech ecosystem.
If you're looking five,
10 years down the line,
what changes, what shifts
are we going to see perhaps also,
with the US market
in this whole triangle?
What big developments can I look for
as I'm now venturing
into my own journey?
Yeah.
A couple of very interesting thoughts.
One, I feel your digital online identity
and how you present yourself digitally
would become so much more important than
anything else.
Right?
Because, you know,
now we are in a situation
we  don't know when the vaccine
is actually going to come
and when the world
will  start seeing each other,
when travel will open.
So, that window
all the networking
that we used to do at conferences,
meet and greet things,
everything's moving online.
So, you got to be very, very good
at how you communicate,
how you think,
and how you position yourself digitally.
So that's going to be a big, big shift
going forward.
Then a lot of shift
that we will also see
in the way people use essential services.
So, for example, health care, food
or any services that we are using
on a day to day basis,
a lot of that is going to move digital.
Instead of going
to a physical diagnostic center,
can you do everything at home.
So, I'm seeing a massive shift there.
And that's where,
you know, the fact that India
has a massive consumer base
and Israel
is building these technologies.
I think there's a lot of synergy
that I see on that front as well.
I think that
all of that sounds incredibly exciting.
I have to say that
I can't believe that I know so little
about this emerging market,
because it's obviously
this is the future.
And I think that any entrepreneur
needs to understand
what are the emerging markets
that are possible.
And I'm extremely excited
to continue this conversation also
in a professional setting
with whatever companies
I'll be building and working together
on finding the synergy
and the solutions to both markets.
Because it just sounds like
this is where we're headed
and you can either be a part of it
or you can ignore it and lose.
You lose out on something
so meaningful.
With this, I really want to thank you
for being so generous with your time
and all the incredible insights
and knowledge that you've shared.
But before we leave,
I have to ask you for three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Your Israel guy.
If you are on Twitter,
please follow me
and spread the good word
of the work we're doing
between India-Israel.
I think it's great opportunity
for everyone to tap into.
Wonderful.
Looking forward to being in touch.
And obviously whoever has a company
and has some interesting technologies
and solutions, I'm sure that they,
that they can reach reach out to you
and share with you
what they're working on, right?
Absolutely, absolutely.
Feel free to reach out to me.
Wonderful.
Thank you very much for joining me.
This is a lot of fun. Thank you.